(Maddie yawns)
- [Mark] All right, Maddie.
Maddie, welcome back.
How have things been since we
spoke about a month or so ago?
- [Maddie] Crazy.
- [Mark] What's goin' on?
- Everything's changing.
- [Mark] We were just
talking a little bit about
the drugs that are on the street,
seems like that's changed
in the last week or two.
- Well, it's actually...
Okay, to be completely honest,
it's been like four
months, around that time,
everywhere has changed and
prices have gone up because,
also I think one of the more
so like main people kinda
moved to a new city.
It's always like, with that being said,
instead of getting a whole ounce
which is like 14 gram, which
is nowhere, seven is a half.
So yeah,
14 grams is like $230
instead of what we used
to get it at like 120.
So people are not being
able to do their jobs.
And then on top of that,
they're mixing fentanyl.
They're not putting in the right chemicals
or cooking it right,
which is causing people to go crazy.
And then people who are doing
drugs such as (mumbles),
crack, crystal,
weed,
all in one,
they're really starting to go crazy
'cause they're mixing the drugs
and not taking care of themselves.
And then listening to people
who have spiritual opinions.
- [Mark] So how are
things for you personally?
- Personally,
I kind of moved downtown actually,
instead of the back streets.
I lost a few people who
I thought I'd trusted
because of,
not liking certain
things that they would do
and sticking up for myself.
I had to go through some
more abuse with some friends
who I really looked up to but,
I know they're going through something
and I'm not mad at them.
But to a certain point
I had to just walk away
from that situation
without getting myself killed or anything.
And there's been just a lot of drama
because people are getting competitive.
(siren wailing)
- [Mark] People are getting what?
- Competitive.
- [Mark] Competitive.
- They're just like, if
they don't like an answer
then they get super mad.
Or
like, if let's say if it's over a guy
then the girls get super like...
They'll gang up on the person.
And then with the whole
thing that happened
with the black guy who
died from the police
it's kind of made it harder
on white people out here.
I've had a couple of
fights because I am white
and I didn't even know
the people, but yeah.
- [Mark] Do you long for a life
outside of this Skid Row situation?
You do?
'Cause last time we spoke,
you were talking about
how you're getting comfortable with it
and you kind of like it in some ways.
- I am comfortable with
it but at the same time
it's always pushing me
to like want to do better
'cause after being out
here, you kind of like,
"Oh, this is the shit.
"No rules, no anything."
And that's this whole fucking lie.
And it's harder on a lot of people.
And then you watch people die.
You hear about stuff.
You watch guys beat up the girls
or boss them around.
Girls out here are...
Well, everybody out here
is just manipulative.
Nobody really tells the
truth unless it's for...
I should know nobody tells the truth.
They just all lie.
And then when somebody
does tell the truth,
they kind of get blamed for it.
Like I've noticed a lot,
everybody blames me.
I'm the first to get blamed.
And that's because I'm the
youngest or I'm the white girl
or it's just the first thing they point at
because that's the easiest.
I've seen that a lot
which maybe it's the crowd
of people I hang out with.
And I haven't really been hanging
out with that many people.
But it's hard 'cause I
don't lie. I don't steal.
And it's been proven over and
over and over again to them.
But it doesn't matter 'cause
it's all about the drugs
out here really to them.
It's the drugs and the sex.
They don't think about like
what could become out of it
or whose feelings are hurting or anything.
- [Mark] But I think a lot of
my viewers, including myself,
watch your story, listen
to your story and,
think it's a 16-year old like yourself,
shouldn't be on Skid Row,
homeless, doing crystal meth.
And what are you doing for money now?
- I'm still recycling.
I trade stuff.
So when I get shoes or
something I sell them.
Or when the looting was going on,
there was a lot of...
I did not go looting,
but yeah there's a lot of merchandise
(mumbles) money off.
- [Mark] I'm sure.
It all came down to Skid Row.
- [Mark] So,
what would help Maddie?
What's out of your reach right
now that actually could maybe
- School.
I can do school and sports.
- [Mark] You would do
what? Finish high school?
- I'd be starting 10th grade.
'Cause I finished ninth grade,
but never made it to 10th.
- [Mark] So like some kind of housing?
Maybe away from Skid Row?
- I'm okay. I'll just get a SRO and a job.
'Cause an SRO,
even though they're disgusting,
they're the way to go actually.
Think about it $45 a month
and it covers water and electricity.
- [Mark] No, but staying on Skid Row,
I see that as problematic, no?
- Not if you're inside,
like if you're in an apartment
people can't mess with you.
- [Mark] No, I'm not
worried about the danger.
I mean, it helps with danger.
It helps with comfort
but it's the drugs that
are still a problem.
- No, not really.
I've been leaning more so off the drugs
'cause they have been
actually really changing.
- [Mark] So regardless of where,
but some kind of housing
provides stability for you?
- I really just think like
school.
I just really want to get back in school.
And then I'ma start doing some classes
at the college tech thing,
LATTC.
And
right now, even though I
kinda moved to a new place
and everything,
I am living with my uncle and
the girl that I call my mom
even though she's not my mom.
And they've been giving me more structure.
- [Mark] Oh, so you've been
staying with your uncle?
- He's not really my uncle,
but I call him my uncle.
- [Mark] Who are they?
They're an older couple?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And they're
looking out for you or?
- Yes.
I have like rules to stay there.
Like I have to clean,
(mumbles) at a certain time.
I have to call them every
30 minutes when I'm gone.
So the normal kid.
- And this is what?
This is their apartment?
- No, it's still a tent,
but better than nothing.
- [Mark] So you're still
in a tent on the street?
- But I haven't like...
Learning a lot more and,
it has been more like so family-like
but not too overwhelming.
And they're not trying to control me
'cause when you try to control a teen,
they're gonna run or
you're gonna push them away
being overbearing.
And being out here,
I've gotten all my partying out of me.
Partying sucks. It doesn't seem fun.
Doing drugs is not as fun as it thinks,
'cause all you do out here
is just party drink, smoke.
And it's nothing.
It's not life.
And most people get carried
away when they're in college
or drop out of college,
or when they're young adults.
Kind of gets stuck in that because,
they haven't done it at a young age.
- [Mark] Well, you see
plenty of people here
that are double, triple,
four times your age
and where are they?
Where do they?
- [Maddie] A lot of people
who are older than me,
I would say I'm a lot more
mature than most people.
And then when it comes
through like rule following.
- No, but my point is
they're still living
on the street in tents.
- Yeah, they don't really care.
They don't see themselves going anywhere.
But I don't blame them 'cause,
a lot of them have been in jail or prison.
And I mean, since they're kids like
younger than what I am right now,
and it kind of fucks them up,
like they've had that
structure all that time,
but they're not able...
The government doesn't see them as equal.
And so like, let's say a
person get hurt by somebody,
and do something to that person,
at like the age of 10.
And then be in jail until they're 21.
It's really not fair for them mentally
'cause they're missing so many things.
And then they don't have
an equal opportunity.
So they just might as
well stay where they are.
It's like people who have
histories shouldn't really be,
held accountable to it for the most part.
I think they should get an equal,
opportunity, when they're out here,
or just out here in the world
after they serve their time
because they already served their time.
They're already punished for
something that they've done.
So why punish them more?
That's why they're out here.
Most people out here hate it.
Most people out here know that
there is nothing better for them
because they can't get a
job like a normal person.
They've lost so many
time people judge them
because of the tattoos that they have,
or things that are on their records.
And
it's not fair.
It's just whatever.
Like how recently there was a cop in LAPD
who got taken off of the force,
because some girl said
he raped her so many years ago
but they had no evidence,
but they didn't question her.
Why would she just come
so many years later
when she could have done
it right then and there
because they're not far in age.
So, with that being said,
just from that story,
it's like did he even rape her?
Or did she get mad at him
and just say that so many years later
just to ruin his
life?
'Cause a lot of people
just want to ruin people,
just to cover up somebody
else or save themselves.
- [Mark] But what I see
in regards to you is,
if you spend enough time
down here in Skid Row
you'll eventually probably
get a similar arrest record
and you'll start doing more
extreme things to make ends meet
or to get your drug or do whatever.
And that's what I think, at your young age
I think myself and a lot of
viewers see an opportunity
to change your direction.
- I wouldn't like...
It does kind of seem
like that, but for me,
I thought that I would be
more like following people.
I'm actually starting to more
so veer towards my own lane.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Even though it's harder
because there's a lot of hate out here.
It scares me. It scares
me seeing everybody else.
- [Mark] Well, there's a much better life
outside of Skid Row in
case you're not aware.
- Yeah. I know that.
I know that for sure.
And
it's like following rules.
Okay, I used to like
being a rule breaker, but,
ooh, I don't even like jaywalking now.
It's like,
or like if a police comes
just shut the fuck up
and let them do their talking.
'Cause I really,
I don't know.
I want to become a nurse
and a lot of people have been saying,
"Oh, why don't you go into nursing?
"Why do you go do the
trade college because,
"you like to take care of people."
But it's whatever,
I'm kind of stuck in a
spot right now, but...
- [Mark] All right, Maddie.
Well, thank you for coming back
and filling us in on
what's going on with you.
And let's see
if we can kind of maybe do
something to help you out.
- I should have like a... I don't know.
Like almost like a camp
for people to come out here
and like spend a week or two
and see what like have
a different viewpoint of
what it's like on the streets
and what it could be like for people
but also how people are out here
'cause even though they
seem like they're crazy,
a lot of them have stories,
and are just mentally ill
or just act like it because,
after a while people like
to tear you down out here
and really don't like
anybody being happy because
they're not happy.
Or people can't stick up
for the wrongdoing because,
that person has a name or reputation.
And we can't change that
because people are scared 'cause,
it is true people do get killed out here
or found behind dumpsters.
And it's no joke.
And a lot of people get away with it.
(vehicle engine revving)
- [Mark] Do you have any dreams
of what you'd like to
see happen in your life?
Is nursing something
you're thinking about?
- Nursing.
I like to travel.
Yeah.
I'll be completely honest.
What is that biggest mountain?
It's not Mount Everest,
is it Mount Everest?
- [Mark] Mount Everest is pretty big.
- The biggest mountain in the world?
- [Mark] In the world?
Might be Kilimanjaro. I'm not sure.
Kilimanjaro might be.
- Well, whatever the biggest one is--
- [Mark] I think Mount
Everest is pretty big.
- Yeah, pretty sure it's Mount Everest.
But I want to hike that.
And even though that
sounds stupid and crazy,
I remember watching a video
and it is kind of dangerous
but that's like my old grandma
kinda to-do-list, bucket list
- [Mark] It's good to have dreams.
- And get a car one day.
Oh, and maybe play for the WNBA,
'cause I've been practicing
basketball a lot,
and I've been pretty good actually.
Even though I still got a
lot to learning to do, but...
- [Mark] Awesome.
All right Maddie, let's stay in touch
and we'll see where...
- Okay.
- [Mark] See what we can do.
Thanks.